bonjour bienvenue sur des gones ltv
actualité spécial chorus 2009 le plus
grand tournoi du monde avec celui d'un
dinar est très certainement on reçoit
pour commenter ce tournoi l'excellent
géant bouffera beauvau rage et le
remords c'est vannes alors géré on va te
présenter toujours pour tous ceux qui te
découvrir aujourd'hui et tues tu es déjà
passé sur des modèles tv plusieurs fois
donc tu te prends d'histoire oui au
départ je suis promené histoire alors au
guidon de passionnés d'échecs
bien sûr en 2100 et l'eau tu fais partie
du comité directeur de la fédération
et alors tu es membres actuellement tu
fais des tâches et en fait des toiles
accès à terme exact de créteil pour
développer donc le jeu d'échecs en tant
qu'outil en tant que support pédagogique
dans toute l'académie alors ça ça c'est
vraiment une révolution c'est nouveau en
fête
de fait je suis le premier fonctionnaire
de l'éducation nationale dans l'histoire
de france qui passe son temps à
développer les échecs on n'a pas trouvé
de vrais j'en ai parlé à leur
environnement fédération n'a pas trouvé
deux précédents donc de fait je suis le
en une fédération délégataire de fait
j'ai envie de dire puisque le l'état
considère qui peut investir de l'argent
dans les échecs - puisqu'ils payent mon
salaire pour que je passe mon temps à
développer les échecs à mettre en
relation les clubs et les établissements
a créé les profs de baccalauréat pour
les handicapés puisqu'il ya une option
sport maintenant pour l'instant réservée
aux handicapés qui va voir sa première
session en juin 2009 c'est quand même
pas rien parce que ça signifie
à partir du moment où il ya une option
baccalauréat signifie doit y avoir un
programme
oui et que les échecs peuvent être
enseignées au lycée sur plusieurs années
bien sûr alors ce qui est fondamental
dans cette nouveauté lors si c'est lié à
la signature de l'accord cadre entre le
ministère de l'éducation et la
fédération française d'échecs a eu en
2009 donc tous alliés en fait aux halles
atouts du jeu d'échecs en tant que
support pédagogique qui permet de
développer des qualités jeu
d'apprentissage qui sont la mémoire la
concentration comme ça des qualités
cognitive alors on a déjà parlé donc
dans l'émission dont je vous ai mythe
évidemment à revoir les émissions que
jérôme était présent les chorus même les
deux de cette année 2009
et alors on a sur 7
sur cette notion non pédagogique des
études qui ont été faites qui démontre
que l'apprentissage du gic permet de
développer ses capacités cognitives et
je crois que à partir de ses premières
études qui étaient des ébauches crois
qu'une grande étude aussi est en cours
qui a une grande étude qui devrait être
lancée sur non seulement sur l'académie
de créteil mais aussi sur d'autres
académies bien chercheurs qui s'appelle
philippe châssis qui travaille au cnrs
donc c'est quand même la fois un gage de
sérieux
il est soutenu par la fédération
évidemment puisque la fédération est
tout à fait attentive à tout ce qui peut
promouvoir le jeu d'échec c'est sous
l'impulsion de notre côté nous on est
prêt à ouvrir toutes les portes
possibles à philippe ceci pour qu'ils
puissent mener son étude aussi bien
auprès des petits que des grands
aussi bien dans des quartiers difficiles
que dans des quartiers plus centraux et
peut-être plus aisés afin d'avoir une
étude assez large sur un nombre d'années
qui sera peut-être restreint mais en
tout cas une étude assez large
territorialement je vais dire est
géographiquement afin de savoir à grande
échelle si le jeu d'échecs développe
réellement des capacités transférables
aux autres matières baroeul l'idée c'est
pas simplement de devenir fort aux
échecs louis ça c'est ce qui n'est pas
forcément le but est l'objectif de
l'académie de créteil et l'éducation
nationale l'idée c'est de voir si par
exemple on développe une donc
l'apprentissage de d'échelle de savoir
est ce que les enfants qui développe cet
apprentissage vont avoir de meilleurs
résultats en histoire en mathématiques
dans les matières classiques on arrive
qu'ils vont être capables aussi de ce
cadre est davantage d'avoir un
comportement plus en adéquation avec ce
qu'on attend d'eux peut-être que ça peut
les disciplines et un roc
ce sont des choses qu'on avait déjà été
remarqué empiriquement oui aux états
unis et dans d'autres pays ce qui
explique aussi l'engouement auprès des
scolaires aux etats-unis dans les
quartiers difficiles
ça c'est un fait il ya environ quarante
mille enfants qui chaque année après les
échecs à new york notamment pour cette
raison on essaye de voir aussi en france
si à grande échelle les enfants
développent des capacités particulières
qui vont pouvoir ensuite transféré aux
autres matières plus classique entre
guillemets et ça il faut le voir
évidemment sur un groupe d'élèves à
grande échelle il faut aussi avoir des
groupes de comparaison c'est comme ça
qu'on fait en sociologie
pour savoir si les non-joueurs aussi se
sont pas améliorées ou pas positionnera
sur une comparaison il faut pouvoir
comparer entre les joueurs et les
nouveaux joueurs voilà non j'aurais pas
savoir si l'on peut pas savoir ça c'est
pas finalement le cours de musique qui
les a toutes choses égales par ailleurs
est ce que ceux qui jouent que ceux qui
jouent vont avoir un comportement
particulier on va voir une nouvelle
attitude face au travail ou de meilleurs
résultats pour de meilleurs résultats
tout simplement mais en même temps on
attend dans l'idéal on attend un petit
peu les deux c'est à dire qu'ils aient
des capacités qu'ils soient raffermi
qu'ils aient une capacité concentration
plus grande et qu'éventuellement il
acquiert une discipline personnelle qui
peut servir la vie de classe c'est à
dire éviter que des incidents tout ce
qui peut être pas que la vie de clavecin
peut-être au-delà tout simplement au
delà tout simplement la vie de classe
ayant de toute façon des incidences et
de retombées personnelles sur chaque
élève bien sûr donc ça c'est très
intéressant alors à noter qu'il ya une
étude faite par michel noir qui va dans
ce sens ce qui démontre voilà qu'à
priori effectivement sur des classes
témoins une qui jouent nus qui joue pas
et une ré à qui on apprend à jouer de
l'autre paraît bien ce qu'ils ont appris
à jouer en 2000 résultats sur des tests
qui sont liées à la mémoire à la
concentration et la résolution de
problèmes notamment mais pas seulement
aussi l'inhibition une réaction intuitif
c'est à dire la capacité à pas faire
tout de suite ce qu'on a envie de faire
oui par exemple on attaque m'en fous est
ce que je le retire tout de suite voilà
ça sert ses capacités à maîtriser les
effectifs les pulsions de façon à dire
bon c'est une idée mais avant de la
piste avant de la soutenir même pas
c'est à dire cette réponse à leur bonne
oui oui donc c'est celle ci c'est celle
qu'on attend de moi c'est celle qu'a
l'air évidente c'est valable aussi en
histoire c'est valable aussi en
mathématiques d'esprit a l'air bon a
priori n'est pas forcément les uns
arrivent ici en chine célèbrent la vie
aussi en général peut-être charge
langonnais certains je crois qu'ils ont
des pulsions d'achats par exemple ça
existe et qui donc peut-être permis de
réfléchir vendu un coup donc voilà donc
ça c'est cette cette préparation
d'études qui très dépendante je pense
que tout le monde attend alors à noter
que sans doute comme les expériences
d'apprentissage de l'échec est déjà en
route depuis quelques années dans
d'autres domaines
dans d'autres lieux que l'écho des
communes créteil plutôt que l'étude
pourraient être réalisées
en relativement peu de temps on n'est
pas obligé de suivre une classe sur
plusieurs années non pas nécessairement
peut comparer déjà des expériences
qu'ils ont qui sont déjà en cours la
firme celle ci travaille aussi du côté
de cannes
bien sûr il ya énormément de licenciés
sur et dans d'autres lieux de france
comme montpellier invite à venir le bâti
notamment qui a obtenu d'ailleurs la
médaille d'argent du ministère des
sports donc sa solide pour le féliciter
chaleureusement oui alors je crois que
c'est notre premier médaillé officiel
aussi oui je crois pas qu'il y en ait
trois ans que lula tiers peut-être sa
théorie reçu quelque chose c'est
possible à vérifier
je dirais pas le contraire donc je me
semble qu'il a reçu plein de choses dans
une distinction mais une médaille
d'argent il servait ce pauvre con c'est
la première fois je pense alors donc
voilà donc on a fait le tour des six de
7,2 cette actualité alors tu as une
autre corde à son arc
tout à fait extraordinaire puisque tu
aussi auteur tu es passionné de
l'histoire de littérature et de théâtre
c'est vrai tu as écris et tu produis
avec eric daries donc une pièce donc de
3 me jérôme jérôme on fera et de éric
darrière une pièce qui se nomme période
des transferts qui voit là qu'on voit
merci la régie c'est vraiment
extraordinaire intima réalisation à la
comédie saint-michel donc jusqu'au 2 mai
jusqu'au 2 mai jusqu'au 2 mai 2009 qui
sera peut-être en conduite après tissé
dans ces cas-là foot il peut y avoir des
prolongations il peut y avoir des
prolongations donc
période de transferts qui est une
comédie c'est la comédie saint-michel
c'est pas par hasard sur des
et bien des jeunes adultes qui se
réunissent pour pour en fait pour un
match de foot qui vont parler de tout
autre chose en fait qu'ils vont faire un
point sur leur vie en fait et envisager
des transferts dans leur vie changer de
job changer de métier cheval à changer
de métier
peut-être avoir des changements au sénat
leur vie amoureuse pour revenir vers
leur club d'origine sait jamais voilà
pourquoi il peut se passer tellement le
ch et un avis pourquoi
voilà donc cette période des transferts
s'est pas seulement la période des
transferts du foot c'est aussi celle des
transferts amoureux on pourrait même le
voir comme période des transferts ou
psychologique oui bien sûr donc c'est un
peu comme au foot se pose est peut-être
le jour de foot je pose toujours la
question en fait dans sa vie de
footballeur dont il sait qu'elle est
courte
comme la vie en général les cours de
savoir tout instant ben finalement est
ce que j'avais pas intérêt à changer de
club en reste et a pas changé il ya des
choix de carrière à faire des choix
c'est vrai aussi dans la vie et donc
c'est un peu l'idée de cette pièce c'est
un moment charnière de la vie des
trentenaires où ils se demandent si l'on
fait les bons choix
ça fait à peu près cinq à dix ans qui
sont dans leur travail peut-être cinq à
dix ans qui sont dans une sentimentalité
établie et il se pose la question de
savoir s'il devrait continuer ou changer
sous peu et pourquoi bayrou et pourquoi
faire pour mieux pour moins bien ou
peut-être que ça a l'air mieux justement
vous avez qu'il devrait inhibé cette
réaction intuitives comme le montre
l'étude de michel noir et diana
réfléchir à deux fois avant de changer
comme ya des joueurs qui qui qui part
dans des grands clubs en espérant y
arrive qu'ils arrivent pas ils sont
obligés de revenir après mon seulement
alors ça peut être bien pas bien ayant
il ya des choix à faire qui sont pas
forcément évident ça dépend le but qu'on
poursuit évidemment donc c'est c'est
très intéressant alors on va repas en
continue à parler de cette pièce tout
simplement pour vous rappeler que c'est
cette pièce se nomme dont période des
transferts
c'est donc à la comédie saint michel et
vous pouvez réserver vos places ignorons
c'est tous les jeudis vendredis samedis
jusqu'au 2 mai 2009 au 01 55 42 92 97 01
55 42 92 97 - réservez vos places pour
aller voir cette superbe comédie alors
on va revenir maintenant sûr
autre coup russe 2009 alors vendre une
superbe partie de ce coût russe entre
deux joueurs mais qu'on adore ici sodebo
net tv pour des raisons différentes
alors ivantchouk d'un côté qui aura les
blancs dans cette partie qui est un des
plus grands génies du jeu d'échec sans
conteste qui sera jamais sans doute
champion du monde pour les raisons oui
mais revenir visiter personnalités
quelqu'un qui peut être un constant
c'est vrai qu' un peu inconstant mais
qui est capable on peut dire du meilleur
comme du pire est capable de battre les
meilleurs joueurs et puis de se montrer
un peu plus terne
voilà et d'avoir des équipes qui
déblaient nervosité a tous un peu de
manque de constance dans le temps mais
capable de battre des kasparov et karpov
ou quelques jours au monde n'a pu
résister à yvonne tout y en a pas un qui
y en a pas un qui soit la bête noire
yvonne show qu'on en fait je crois que
l'on peut pas dire il joue pas le joueur
les jouets pièce il a peur de rien c'est
un vrai génie absolu et alors ils font
face à un autre joueur qui s'appelle
radjabov t mouradia goff qui or lui est
un jeune joueur qui fait partie de la
jeune garde va vêler car yakine les 40
cm
voilà toute cette jeune génération les
maquereaux aussi d'ailleurs puisqu'on
est à peu près du même âge est alors à
diabo of qui lui alors la particularité
qu'on aime beaucoup sur diagonale tv
très spécial c'est le seul joueur
aujourd'hui dans le top
mondiale 20 meilleurs joueurs du monde à
jouer
l'estonienne alors faut savoir que
l'estonienne c'est quand même une
ouverture avec les noirs qui a une
histoire tout à fait particulière qui a
été joué par les plus grands champions
du monde paraît surtout les attaquants
dont notamment les deux plus grands sans
doute bobby fischer et garry kasparov
alors les stan a été abandonné leur
faire raconter l'histoire parce que
c'est vraiment il ya une renaissance là
avec rajab obtenir une tentative en tout
cas il souffre aussi
mais il tente fiché à la casse parfois
jouer cette ouverture avec succès et
kasparov a arrêté de jouer cette
ouverture cancre amis en fait à inventer
une attaque pour contrer les cévennes
qui s'appelle attaque baïonnette connais
un peu cette histoire ou pas où est
cette attaque ce type d' attaques de pas
très bien alors c'est officiellement
pour en parler alors on va l'avoir
violemment dans cette partie ça tombe
bien qu'on voit c'est pas bon
et en fait un des rares à trouver des
idées pour contrer cette attaque qui a
tué l'estonienne prenantes pendant
presque dix ans savoir ça fait beaucoup
de mal à jouer ça et maintenant à dire
rejoue cette cette ouverture avait des
succès pas négligeable donc tout à fait
intéressant donc qui permet de redonner
espoir à tous les fans de l'estonienne
dont je suis pas ce que veut donc quand
on aime fille chérie kasparov
on a eu l'habitude de voir des
estoniennes superbe mais là on est au
chorus 2009 on arrive en dessous des
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui joue face
à radjabov une estonienne dont on va
voir que c'est vraiment une ouverture
extraordinaire
alors on y va il va en tout cas les
blancs donc on va regarder le côté noir
parce que ça doit nous intéresser de me
recevoir évidemment du côté noir est ce
que ça donne alors qu'amélie f6 de la
part de la gauche c'est ça l'idée
après ces quatre g6 voilà l'idée de
l'estonienne c'est qu'on développe le
fou à l'est on est plutôt du côté ouest
quand on voit de ce côté là on fait en
général on regarde la partie de malades
selon le thème lent et ça fait plutôt
l'est alors donc le fou et développer la
à quand on développe le flou sur la case
b4 ici on parle du west end
ça dépend d'où on s'en fout donc on joue
aussi ses phobies 4c l'ouest donc là on
est sur l'est indienne après câble et
ses trois fous g7 on a un fou en
chantier taureau qui à long terme vise
aussi bien la case des quatre cultes
cavagnan c3 que le pion en b2 et
éventuellement la tour qui se trouvera
par exemple aussi et alors ils
contrôlent aussi la couse la case aux
cinq sur lequel on va vouloir contratas
philo simple parce que pour l'instant on
voit que les noirs abandonnent
complètement le contrôle du centre et
que les blancs se constitue un centre de
pions puissant et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que je continue à faire les choux gras
on me laisse de la place au centre j'en
prends je la prends des 6 x 2 le pari
votre choix donc ça c'est une cette
année l'option normal il ya plusieurs
choix ici les blancs peut jouer la
variante sa mishkin variante très solide
au centre avec f3 mais qui implique des
manoeuvres de pions lente et c'est donc
une autre type de jeu on peut aussi
jouer le coup câble f3 on peut envisager
aussi le coup j'ai trois angles là il
choisit donc food petit rock car les f3
de la part donc on prépare le rock on a
un joli centre de pions et là tout de
suite
la réaction centrales classiques e5
alors vous me direz attention puisque
les blancs peut reprendre le 5 et après
sur la prise le cavalier peut prendre
imaginons la variante 85 si on prend 1,5
on échangerait par exemple les dames
d'abord d'emprunt pour prendre sinon
c'est le noir qui change
hélas si on essaie de gagner le pion de
5 sa marque pas tout simplement à cause
de tes relie prend le cas mais puisque
le fou j'ai cette attaque le câble inc
donc ya pas de vraie menace
on récupère le pion et l'avantagent
blanc au centre a complètement disparu
ou s'est évaporé la position évidemment
tout de suite et galets blancs
abandonner tout avantage de d'ouverture
lisez facilement donc c'est pas on peut
pas vraiment prendre le pion aux 5
si ce n'est qu'on veut égaliser la
position mais ce qui risque et péril
d'hébron alors petit petit rock voilà et
la corvette c6 alors ça c'est l'idée de
la grande barrière de l'estonienne je
sens le client sait si j'ai pas peur
d'être chassés par des 5 parce que je
veux ramener le cavaliere le set qui
après en recettes ce cavalier va pouvoir
soutenir la poussée par exemple f5 et
éventuellement après des échanges se
recycler soit par g6 puis après f4 et 4
soi même des fois par g8 soutenir le
cavalier pcistes qui peut bouger est
remplacée et c'est donc scellé mal de
cavaliers il faut bien comprendre que
dans ses variantes où on abandonne
centre de l'échiquier à l'adversaire il
va bien falloir attaquer un endroit et
si possible aux marges de ce centre soit
par la poussée ces cinq soit par la
poussée f5 qui permet de dynamiter le
centre blanc voilà donc le coup
cavaliers 7 est tout à fait logique dans
le sens où il va effectivement soutenir
cette poussée f5 tout à fait à noter
aussi que ce que cavalia sinon cela n'a
pas peur des cem et fait pression sur
des quatre là la menace des noirs c'est
d'envisager des prises en d4 et des
langues le thème du sacrifice avait des
thèmes de sacrifices avait des idées
d'ouverture etc et les blancs du mal en
général à garder le centre ouvert alors
ils peuvent tenter un coup comme fou le
3 mai ccdh aux petits de varane qui
peuvent poser des problèmes par ailleurs
alors des 5 est le coup le plus usité
sûr c'est la grande variante cavalier e
set maintenant et orly décès on va
sentir ce qui valide par exemple 1 8 par
exemple 5 et préparer la poussée f5 avec
une tour qui est derrière et en échange
évidemment d'un de centre blanc formé
fermer les maisons vont attaquer cette
septième de pions qui est là en créant
eux avec éventuellement un qui ont eu
quatre derrière une attaque contre leur
à blanc et les bleus vont essayer de
casser cette chaîne de piolenc c'est ça
l'idée générale par une attaque à l'ale
avec b 4 c 5 soutenu par un fou et 3p
ventura par une tour soit en baisse -
c'est une dame qui peut venir en d3
essayer de casser de ses structures et
de pénétrer sur l'ale dame à savoir
appris qu'elle attaque va prendre le
dessus sur l'autre
donc c'est pour ça qu'une parents qui
plaît au jour d'attac on n'est pas dans
une bande symétrique on est dans une
grande variété
l'un a tapé dans l'autre a les droits et
le premier qui passe à gagner voilà b4
celle attaque baïonnette alors avant
cramique avant que kramnik vous secoue
on pensait que ce coût était pas bon
puisque le coût à 5 pose un problème aux
blancs on peut pas protéger avec à trois
puisque dans ce cas là y aurait à
prendre b4 et tout reprendre tour si
évidemment si les blancs jouent b5
après b6 c'est fini on a plus jamais de
face à la mêlée là mais ils ont perdu
imaginons b5 b6 comment voulez vous
passer ces cinq c'est impossible on
prendre d'une pions n'ont jamais
reprendre ici d'une pièce de londres à
plus de jeu elle dame cardinaux et il
n'y a plus que les noirs conduits
violainois absolument donc c'est
vraiment pas une bonne idée et mes
chroniques à trouver le coup intéressant
ici dans cette danse est dense est dans
cette position fou à 3 c'est ça la
taille baïonnette c'est cette idée fou à
3 parce qu'en fait les blancs ont pas
peur de la prison b4 quel bon coup prise
suivi du coût des six qui verrouille la
casse est simple parce qu en fait l'idée
des blancs cd rw mais en fait c'est ça
l'idée chronique des datas gainey on
veut je vais jouer à 4 qu'on peut pas
empêcher avec les noirs et a5 est en
fait j'ai fait bien b6 parce que si je
prends un imbécile qu'on reprend du pied
si les blancs prennent si les noirs
prennent de publicis mais je n'aurai pas
de problème à jouer c'est saint caprais
et si on laisse cependant bcg affaibli
le pion v6 qui va lui-même devenir une
cible sur une colonne google donc voilà
et c'est ça qu'a posé des problèmes
kasparov et qui a fait qu'il a abandonné
cette variante mai
radhia goff joue lui une autre idée il
joue cavalier 1,8
donc il n'a contre attaque pas avec avec
hassen qui laisse faire les blancs la
poussée ces cinq intérieurs alors les
blancs d'abord joue d'abord le coup à 4
l'idée c'est qu'ils veulent envisager de
jouer fou à 3 pour protéger la poussée 5
en ayant déjà joué le pion ici parce
qu'il peut toujours poussé à 5
éventuellement casser des défenses f5 le
coût normal libération normal coup de
coude attaque surtout au centre d'attac
l'idée pour le nom je commence à faire
pression évidemment sur quatre et un
jour le câble et m6 je veux forcer les
blancs à prendre même en 5 et de ramener
un pion qui ont joué au centre avant
du coup un contrôle contre eux sur les
centres avec ses deux fonctions mobiles
et puis le pion 4,6 à +4 le fou g7 a à
nouveau un espoir de pouvoir rayonner
abc sursis si les pions deviennent
mobiles après la menace 4 va libérer ce
fou g7 qui devait monstrueux déjà
regardé il ya le cavalier ces trois-là
tour là mais même quand y'a pas ça
souvent le fou s'activent soit sur la
case 5 soit sur la case des cartes et un
petit oeil arrière sur le fond tout ça
c'est l'idée générale de l'estonienne
donc ici à 5 toujours préparés pour yves
en dessous de la pousser ses 5 joue à 5
donc j'empêche des éventuelles des six
plus tard parce que la prise ici je
pourrai pas reprendre du plus grand tour
je mets pression ici sur les 15 secondes
donc je prépare l'attaquant fait de la
chaîne de pion par ces cinq cavaliers 6
de la part des noirs d'encre à d'abord
redit à réussissent d'ailleurs pourquoi
partir pour revenir mais j'ai joué cinq
comment ça change tout et maintenant je
n'attaque vraiment le 4è deux pions qui
attaquent le pion le cadre une idée
possible c'est ce que fait
j'ai cinq en cas de reprise dans lequel
je peux envisager de prendre ce soir sur
m6 et après quand je prendrai sur cette
j'attaque la dame il faudra bien
reprendre je peux pas prendre tout on
donné j'ai un problème
donc tous les cinq hélas alors qu
intéressant droite du golf classic
hostile en italien calais h5 donc
j'enlève cette prise ici et le kali peut
souvent se recycler sur
sur la cazelle 4,4 alors j'ai pas peur
d'emprise de sokal et parce que les 7
est mal placée en fait pour l'instant
parce qu'il tape sur du c'ur du sur du
dur il va des fois c'est l'on a on peut
jouer rouach huit cavaliers
j'ai vite mais c'est lent et là je peux
mais envisager de jouer h6 des choses
comme ça et le fou un problème de savoir
où il va suivent à quatre on peut avoir
g5 ou g3 et f4 qui prend le fou vous
pouvez prix donc les blancs qui
choisissent de prendre entre 5 et après
la prison j'ai pris 25 le câblage cinq
ici ont gardé un problème puisqu'il est
un peu en l'air et des blancs peuvent
envisager décalé prendre 5 et en cas de
prismes le pion le caillage s'inquiètant
prix sauf que là le câble et c3 et
toujours en prise aussi hélas taux court
derrière il attend derrière donc on peut
pas le faire tout de suite mais ça
affaiblit la position du câblage 5
maintenant le problème c'est que ça a
libéré les pions sans trop pour jouer le
4 avec libération du coup j'essaie
l'idée de reprendre avec le plonger est
relativement classique on la retrouve
aussi dans l'angle aise dans certaines
variantes du côté blanc oui l'idée c'est
vraiment de réussir à constituer à
nouveau plein centre mais là cette fois
ci ce sont les noirs qui il ya deux
idées gars le centre ici tu es fort
évidemment il ya aussi la duplicité du
roi à suite et tours j'ai vite avoir une
la colonne g sur laurent blanc ça aussi
c'est important est de jouer
éventuellement cavaliers g6 puisque
maintenant la case celle ci c'est libre
qu'elle g6 à une fois qu'on aura résolu
le clouage du lien sur 17 alors le
ku'damm d2d blanc comme on vient de le
voir protège le cavalier c3 donc menace
car les 35 bardet parce que si câble et
prend 1,5 maintenant si on reprend du
fou après fou prend cavaliers on a gagné
un pion parce qu'il ya les cas on ne
peut pas reprendre avec les blancs il y
aurait simplement les chocs de pièces et
au passage on n'a qu'à les pions ou 5
donc ça explique le coup suivant nos
radjabov qui maintenant revient une
nouvelle fois rien donc les manoeuvres
de cavaliers sont ont été faites afin de
forcer la prison
là l'idée est là c'est l'heure pour i
want you de la tacc classique
maintenant c'est 5 il a déjà les dames
des jo la laddh
il faut gagner de l'espace donc alors
vraiment l'idée évidemment c'est
d'ouvrir à terme on va prendre sur des
six on pourra éventuellement même joué à
six pour empêcher que le nom je m'assis
on peut envisager après des tours c'est
un des cavaliers b5 pour prennez trait
sur la casse c'est cette part d un
problème qu'on attaque créé la tour on
peut venir sur la case aussi ce faire
une fourchette forçant le fou à
s'échanger ce qui peut être très
embêtant discussion des six après sera
sur une colonne ouverte
c'est l'idée générale évidemment les
noirs ont des ressources bien sûr alors
on voit la suite
tout d'abord le coup d'essai talent fou
17 et souvent joué contre kavala des 5
on n'aura pas peur d'en salade et
changer parce que ce cavalier très
pénible pour la taxe il disparaît certes
on a donné une paire de fou mais on a
plus de problème vraiment d'attaqué sur
cette colonne ça va être très difficile
pour les blancs de passer sans ce
cavalier
ce cavalier souvent fondamentales
poussées l'attaqué ou 17 je lis aussi
les tours c'est important à terme les
gens pêche aussi la pousser ses six ans
et des idées toutes ces idées font food
et c'est le fouillis bien placés en
dix-sept bonne idée la dîme on trouve
toujours dans l'idée leur maintenance
est justifiée aussi le coup et 5 p 5
mais ça alors ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
fort il n'a pas peur il en dessous de 2
de lâcher entre guillemets ce pion ce
pion c5
il veut pouvoir jouer soit décider
soi-même ses 6 mais non là j'ai deux
pions fort alors si les noirs prennent
on a dit lecavalier prends tu sois là je
prends le 5
je prends notre côté donc les ça casse
le sang prenant largement c'est pas bon
donc des cinq et un très bon coup et
l'idc silice éventuellement b6 pourquoi
pas à 6 aussi suivi de ces six ou un
récit sans vraiment il ya plein plein de
possibilités là les noirs sont sous
pression ici en général la règle faut
pas bouger il faut continuer la pression
qu'on veut mais de l'autre côté voir au
centre
c'est ce que va faire radjabov
tranquillement ils paniquent pas et
jouent le tranquille fouet vite l'idée
qu'il veut recycler son fou soit angers
6 soit pourquoi pas 5
et surtout ne pas bouger ici ça sa
chaîne de dieu sait si ce donc c'est ce
qu'on vient de dire donc là les bleus
risquent de perturber maintenant la
chaîne plomb là il faut faire quelque
chose parce que si les blancs prennent
en 17 secondes
évidemment mais pour ces 7 devient fait
tout et tout et tout est cassé donc il
faut réagir par b6 ses forces et donc
c'est là qu'on voit que le pion à 5 est
bien placé et la torah et derrière on
peut prendre à tout moment et avoir une
pression sur le clown à ce qui permettra
un écart des changes de tours déjà de
dévier la dame de la mettre sur le côté
ce qui peut être intéressant
cabaye h4 maintenant de la part du monde
choc alors commence à faire une petite
pression ici sur le pion ipsen peut
envisager de d'attaquer ce plan parce
que si si les noirs jouent trop tôt un
coup comme eux quatre ils vont se
heurter à des f3 des choses comme ça qui
vont casser le centre de noir n'ont pas
intérêt à se lancer dans quoi que ce
soit au centre de toute façon tant que l
ont pas la possibilité de mener une
véritable attaque
alors voilà ils peuvent pas trop a lancé
ni d' attaque sur le roi ni date à
caussens temps que ses pions bougent pas
assez remercier blanc joue en f3 ce
genre de truc qu'on peut envisager de
jouer le cas et tant que ça bouge pas
dès qu'on bouge c'est pas bon on
s'affaiblit en fait alors fouet cette
voie là l'autre idée de vol à l'idée de
rajab of you et set je fais pression
maintenant sur ton des cinq car les six
carlos est fou et 7 et je défendu que
deux fois lors d'un autre côté le fou
ici fait un clouage mais pour l'instant
ça tient pour les médias commencent à
avoir une pression potentielle sont ceux
qui ont des 5 fu détroit voilà l'idée de
radia boivent pression sur h5 foulée 3
je veux forcer en fait ce pion ces
centres à bouger à vous j'ai justement
voilà il ya aussi un centre bougies
s'affaiblit oui c'est ce qui est bien
c'est de garder la mobilité de ses plans
c'est pourquoi radjabov continue dans
l'idée lâche cette idée de
de pression son dessin et vient angers 6
avec son fou protéger son pion et garder
la mobilité de ses plus hauts niveaux
les bouger au bon moment c'est peut-être
bien insisté justement sur le sur le
fait que pousser par exemple 4 qui peut
apparaître en tant que joueur j'ai six
nous et qu'on s'a de menace réelle ça
s'est affaiblie maintenant les cavaliers
vont pouvoir aller s'installer en f4
voilà exactement sur quatre 04 on va
faiblir notamment la cazelle 4 le
cavalier va être trop content à une fois
qu'on aura vu la tour pour éviter le feu
le g7 mais devenir en deux puis henri iv
avec une très belle case en f4 il serait
ce une double pression sur j'insiste
pression sur la case aussi ça avec
fourchette et on fait toujours attention
bouger un pion pour attaquer une pièce
ça implique quelque chose de définitif
puisque les pions ne revienne pas en
arrière c'est évident mais on a tendance
à l'oublier
donc après tout les 6 il ya quand même
donc on va dire il vaut toujours le coup
f3 donc là c'est aussi ça empêche 4
donc c'est un cookie classiques d'antan
dans l'east india lors d'autant plus
qu'on a fermé ici cette grande diagonale
souvent des échecs pénible en
l'occurrence là il y en a plus on
corrige ou f3 avec moins de danger a
priori il peut avoir une autre idée pour
les blancs l'idée évidemment
actuellement c'est qu'ils jouent sur une
scène qui est aussi un pion un pion
faible puisqu'il peut pas défendu tout
de suite sur la nature si les noirs
jouent eux-mêmes f4 ils affaiblissent
terriblement la case leucate qui devait
une très belle classe pour cavaliers
donc ça c'est à éviter ou absolument et
donc les blancs veulent forcer veut les
avoir comme idée de jouer g4 pour
affaiblir définitivement cette case
excellent 6 7 6 options et septembre
c'est la case 4 qui est très faible et
kiên giang a souvent clé pour les noirs
pour les blancs pardon dans la dans la
dent les seniors dames 8 nov l'idée
c'est d'enlever le clouage ici sur ce
fou et donc il ya une menace c'est le
plan des singles potentiels
il faudra d'abord joué rouages suite
pour éviter les courages sur cette
grande menace qui est classique aussi
donc ni d'un v8 est souvent cette idée
on peut avoir aussi d'idées en cas de
prise de remplacer par la dame qui du
coup à une action de défense sur f5 sur
la case cas potentiellement qui peut
être atteint et aussi sur la colonne du
roi 3 h suite tour g8
il peut y avoir des idées de maths watch
d'ailleurs voilà un coup classique
prophylactique roi suit un second se
cache
voilà très classique la case imiter
bonne souvent soit pour une tour soi
même pour un cavalier avec l'idée je
sors le cavalier et je le remplace après
celui-là par celui-là g2 beau cavalier
qui peuvent s'auto protéger fous ces
deux de la part du 25e consolide le
contrôle sur le cac ce dessin qui avait
un problème non est ce que comme on l'a
dit en jouant rachat suite les deux
cavaliers maintenant attaquer maintenant
on joue un fossé de ya pas de problème
casey cinquième éléphant nuit là mais
100 dont claudine une attaque continuer
évidemment si on défend avec une tour
baisse à défendre mais du coup la tour
et pas actives pour autre chose donc
c'est toujours bien
lisez des pièces à la défense d'un pion
et là l'idée d'yves en tout j'ai 4 alors
ça c'est intéressant
gk donc c'est l'idée d'affaiblir ce
pyongyang comme on l'a dit s'il ya une
prise qui est ce qui se fait sur le côté
on peut envisager après une prise en g 6
du fou d'avoir une très belle case ou
quatre noms c'est un pseudo sacrifice en
fait qui permet regardé par après cavale
et pranger 6 par exemple câbles hypron
v6 on peut prendre du plomb en bref le
cavaliere 6 est clouée sur la caennaise
et on a une belle case super bien et en
général les noms s'en sortent pas les
blancs ont l'avantagé en dépit du pion
du pian passé puisque le cavalier
bloqueurs en cas très très fort qu'elle
a aucun non seulement il est très fort
parce qu'il peut pas être attaquée par
un pur noir il contrôle des cases dans
le camp ennemi mais en plus il musèle le
pion aux 5 et donc le fou g7 qui devient
un poids moindre imposition
donc ça c'est terrible parce que le foot
est sceptique ir muret parle dans les
stades jens et c'est pas bon
donc j'ai quatre voilà l'idée donc là il
faut que rajab autres joujoux
extrêmement précis et donc il joue le
coup regardez comme j'ai dit c'est bon
pour un caroline y compris pour celui-là
il s'est qualifié vite
donc l'idée l'âge libère ici la colonne
dam tour avec l'idée sans doute pour les
noirs de prendre quand même on j'ai
cadré de sacrifier la dame qu'entre les
deux contre les deux tours est en
général de tout son plus fort qu'une
dame donc se reprendre le ramène la
deuxième tour on a deux très forte
autour et une vraie attaque sur le drap
blanc faut pas croire que les deux tours
sont inférieurs la dame blanche c'est le
contraire les deux tours seront
supérieures tour 1,4 alors là alors
c'est aussi des bas 9 classique dans les
stalles yen y vont tous qu'en jouant
tour à 4 jaunes en relève de la prise il
faut que j'essaie et je mets une tour
pour la défense ici donc je pourrais
envisager une vente en europe 1
c'est ça l'idée donc je mets la défense
parfois même la tour dans certaines
positions des statines va sur la case à
3 pour protéger la troisième rangée
normes et de coulisses et les manoeuvres
classique non seulement en espagne mais
dans l'espagnol si on peut retrouver ce
genre d'idée on tour à quatre bons coups
j'empêche gens paient cette possibilité
radjabov se démonte pas continuer un
coup classique dans les stalles yens 3 8
ça c'est intéressant aussi donc j'active
la tour qui jouait pas je viens au
centre et pourquoi pas mais je soutiens
une pousse possible plus ses centrales
e4 ultérieure après ce temps j'ai un
problème parce que j'aime vis-à-vis avec
la tour eiffel donc qu'a prise le 4
j'aurais j'aurai un problème et c'est
tout à fait jouable
les blancs mais n'en profite une fois
que la tour est plus là pour faire
approuver 6 à prendre les six et to race
est une impression sur l'option c7 la
tournée évidemment étant parti je peux
venir à sète et j'ai un problème et
noires pour protéger ce sont ces sept si
j'enlève le cavalier ossètes hiva oa la
dame protégerait mais il serait venue
relancer vite serait très mal placé
ensuite cela n'empêche pas les blancs de
rester sur cette septième rangée avec
tours 17
exactement et ensuite de rentrer
éventuellement avec le retour l'autre on
pourrait venir il faut faire attention
aux contre-attaqués mais son carter
mattern voilà s'il pense et septembre
comprenaient que là il ya un pion c'est
pas ses protégés qui deviendra donc se
doit cette le bon coup ses tours ses 8
alors c'est pas un vrai problème et on a
joué des tours à huit tours s'il met les
blancs reviennent un jour de tour à
quatre tracés pour saignement je protège
d'influencé 7 donc j mobilise la
tourasse est ici c'est vrai qu'elle est
active de l'autre côté tant que ça tient
elle fait pas vrai faire une plus non
donc faut pas avoir peur de ce genre de
coups défensifs faut bien tenir la
baraque cette chaîne de pions elles
tiennent grâce aux pions c'est cette
attention quand même toutefois d'un
certaines bonnes possibilités
les blancs des fois sacrifie ans et 7
pour prendre après le tube et 6 ou qui
ont des cistes et se retrouver deux
pions pas scellier qui veulent une pièce
oui largement même des fois plus
quelquefois plus parce que deux pions
passé lié en cinquième et sixième rangs
j'ai aussi leur dos dames cordoba non
mais il se révèle quelques fois que
fortune tour bien sûr et bien du mal à
les arrêter
exactement donc attention alors c'est
l'heure pour young soo maintenant
d'échangés le fou un g6
ouais c'est des positions très général
très peu d'actifs mais assez
positionnelle d'un projet six choisis
radjabov l'intéressent en jouant d'un
projet si c'est que j'enlève le
vis-à-vis tour d'un parce que si les
prix du plongeur consolider ma case est
saine mais j'ai des problèmes active et
puis j'ai affaibli ma colonne âge c'est
pas forcément le but je préfère dans des
colonnes ouverte ici pour pour pénétrer
à tout moment essayé de contre attaquer
son roi blanc qui reste l'idée
principale analyste immobilier tour g1
voilà rom et la tour en face de la dame
intéressant donc radar reviendrait vii
il serait peut-être content à d'abord de
faire tôt à farnham g6 et de faire
pourquoi pas une répétition de la
ivantchouk essaie de continuer la partie
non pas de répéter les coups c'est tout
à son honneur il s'attendait peut-être
pas à répéter non plus d'ailleurs
peut-être pour gagner du temps la
pendule éventuelles
torje trois coups de coups de
consolidation et pourquoi pas pou
d'attac parce que tourache trois
problèmes font savoir exactement le fou
ces deux tapes sur h7 et avec courage 3
ça commence à devenir pénible de tenir
cette position où on peut plus bouger
les pions est-ce que dès qu'on bouge on
se prend entourage tête suivi commencent
à être sous pression a baissé leur
souvent dans ce genre de position pour
les stalles viennent d'ouvrir la
position regarder ya il ya une masse de
pièces ici qui n'attend que de se
détendre qu'on en ressort un fou g7 qui
n'attend que l'opposition s'ouvre pour
jouer pour entrer en jeu
une dame f7 avec une tour et fait qu'ils
sont prêts à rentrer dans le camp blanc
un cavalier 7 qui est protégé par lequel
il jouit donc il risque par un chose qui
fait pression sur des 5 mai qui n'attend
que de passer par soit par f5 soit par
g6 plus tard pour venir en jeu un quart
les g8 qui n'attend aussi que de sortir
pour participer à la table tout ça
n'atteint que ce cas se détendent et
très souvent le bon coup ils arrivent
eux quatre d'autant plus là on va casser
cette semaine deux pions forcément le
plus riche 3 va tomber donc derrière le
projet 4 aussi on va ouvrir la position
et c'est en général plus avantageux pour
les noirs que pour les blancs cette
ouverture ici donc là on ne peut pas
drainer calcul c'est tellement complexe
sa position il ya trop de choses mais on
voit bien que la sellor et ça libère le
fou g7 se fou devient le trader déjà ans
le 5 il va faire pression sur la
trajectoire
donc là ils vont tous jouer un coup de
leurs placements
à noter ici que
avec ses trois sites potentiellement
d'alata car il sait pas une vraie menace
mais il peut y avoir très vite des
possibilités de ce côté là cavalier 2 de
la part de la part du groupe de profiter
de quatre pour profiter soit la soie et
4 soi même des cartes avec la case aussi
derrière alors il faut réagir très vite
cabaye f6 de la part regarder comme ça
survienne trio est comme une carrière ça
revient ça repart celui-là il est allé à
8 après 1 h 56 il revient ici en 6
pression sur des 5
mais comme je serai avec lyon c'est pas
évident la menace peut être d'en prendre
des cinq carrément voire pourquoi pas
même cavalier qu'elle les prend il ya
aussi possibilité mêlant d'ouvrir le jeu
à tout moment ça de maistre avant
compliqué composition car la f4 c'est
l'idée d'yves en tout cas donc je veux
ni hao 6 je gagne un temps sur la tour
et fuite je peux aussi changer de projet
7 qui est souvent le très bon fou à la
fois de défense et l'attaqué des noirs
eux pro x3 donc j'essaie d'ouvrir la
position et je menaces recensées mais
aussi pions cavaliers prendre un câble
les projets carte qui est très fort
quel point les quatre j'aurais sans
doute pas peur sur cavaliers aussi de
sacrifier un jeu je prendrai sans doute
angers cadre du cavalier avec une belle
position attention aussi il peut y avoir
des caraïbes 4 fourchette dam tour vous
voir dan fouts forçant le fou à prendre
et j'aurai deux pions passé lié absolue
alors là ça serait est un pion en f
ouais bah oui parce qu'en empirant ils
font plus soutenue par dame et tourne à
rien donc j'aurai pas peur de jouer ce
genre de coups donc il faut réagir très
vite
donc j'ai pris cinq voilà faut empêcher
c'est ce coup qu à leucate qui serait
qui est très fort ici donc radjabov
choisit maintenant de il faut il faut il
faut réagir et continuer son expansion
car les prélèvements des singes choisi
de prendre le pion dessin alors peut
être un souci parfois ce genre de coup à
cause du coût par exemple fou
four b3 puisqu'il clouage années si bien
défendu et le simple dame prend f5 tient
la position parce que derrière il ya f2
et fun d'avoir d imaginer que les blancs
jouent un coup comme si bien je gagnais
une pièce par cavalier prend des scènes
mais tout simplement avec deux c'est
déjà très en bêta et je peut plus
arrêter il faut oui c'est cela je peux
pas arrêter je suis obligé de jouer un
coup comme fou ces 4 par exemple de
donner la dame si je joue fous ces
quatre cavaliers prendre il ya même dame
échec d'un échec
que font les que font les plans surtout
f2b il ya f2 échec souffrent quand on
prend et ma tante ou le montrer tout
simplement trop de dames vous prend pour
prendre mat
donc vous voyez ça va vite donc c'est
tactique déjà on est dans l'east enyele
ça devient active donc allez prends des
5 on peut pas on n'a pas le temps de
faire fougue et 3 il faut il faut
absolument somptueux f5 maintiennent
cette batterie il faut absolument pas
pour les langues que les noirs
réussissent à faire sauter ce bouchon
sinon ils vont soutenir leurs pions et
ça va aller à dame
c'est là où est la différence entre le
foot cases blanches qui certes est
attaquant ici mais n'est pas défensif
donc le fou j'ai deux ministres est là
et ils vendent pas de problème les noir
e on ne fout g7 qui à la fois plus
attaquent à tout moment faire un échec
éventuel ci a besoin venir en 5 attaqué
aussi la tour j'ai 3 mais aussi sert de
défense au beurre noir donc la
différence entre ces entre séville et
contrôlant plus magasin qui empêche la
tour de revenir pour défendre et donc
exactement contrôle aussi la casa et
sept tours mais finalement elle fait pas
grand chose ça fait pas un choix à
l'immobilisme tomé
elle n'est pas allée pas très très
active vaut pas plus que la tour c 8 ces
deux tours se neutralisent pour price 3
de la part de blanc dont sage sage
décision il est blanc ont compris qu'il
faut absolument pas ouvrir cette colonne
f voilà les noirs choisissent d'échangé
de livres 4 parce que la menace
maintenant de venait effectivement de
faire un four b3 faire un courage très
pénible d'impro f4 de la part des blancs
est fou et 6 tranquillement de la part
de radia beau fils veut empêcher les
mêmes attentions en 2006 qui serait
pénible ça gagne pièce double il ya une
fourchette ça me prendrait pour chez
infosys verrouille cette position four
b3 assez c'est l'heure pour les blancs
maintenant que il ya plus de pression
sur f5 d'attaquer la dame damashek bella
l'on peut pas reculer avec le fou il va
falloir s'échanger on peut plus rien
pour pas reculé de 4,26 on aura en aura
un problème par exemple sur flash 6 tout
simplement garder faut 5 et c'est leur
attaque le fou et 2 commencent à menacer
match 2 le seul coup se sont joués par
une dame des deux pour essayer de
contrôler à la fois le fou et le pion h2
mais dans ce cas là tout simplement d'un
proto perla tôt donc on peut pas éviter
les changes les fous price is aimer les
noix sont contents pourquoi les gens
sont contents parce qu'un peu tout
reproche 6 il ya pression maintenant ça
y est sûre le pion aux cinq qui
deviennent truc regardez comme la quasi
vide devient disponible aussi pour l'
attaque contre laurent blanc la torah 7
est quand même toujours hors jeu donc ce
coup on peut jouer un peu quand on veut
et tout de suite il ya une vraie menace
donc c'est les blancs qui commence à
avoir des problèmes malgré que c'est un
pion passé mais ça me faut pas céder
sous pression le fou fou s'est vite
voilà exactement où s'est vite font ici
il faut aussi ce pardon vous insistez
attaque la tour s'est vite et protège le
plan excepte et surtour cf-18 la menace
des blancs c'est à l'épreuve scénique
tout simplement d' équité imparable
donc les chambres a bien été une
libération et que les pièces noires sont
toutes du côté droit il reste immense
voilà il manque une pièce à la peine
cette fameuse tour à cette voie là qu'on
croyait offensive et qui en fait est
génial et si ça saute
c'est que le problème c'est qu'il peut
rien pour défendre le roi parce que
derrière ça va ça va très très vite la
dame devient presque suffisante pour
mater le roi puisque adam effet mat
c'est vite fait il suffit une autre
pièce et ça va très vite et on peut pas
faire grand chose avec les blancs s'ils
ont joué un coup passif par un coup de
défense comme tours 1 tout simplement on
perd on perd le fou est ce que tu
reprends foot ça bouge pas si on s'est
laissé de sortir le fouet à cause de
cette menace par exemple qu'on fout 17
ça reste encore faisable mais dans ce
cas là il ya calibre 9 5
c'est très très dur le problème pour les
poulets noire les noirs vont plus
pouvoir menacé de sortir ce cavalier
avec une attaque une attaque sur la dame
on n'a pas peur de changer de tour pour
la dame parce qu'il peut y avoir une
attaque très puissante derrière avec
avec avec avec la dame
donc il ya déjà difficultés pour ici
pour courir en dessous pour trouver un
coup un coup correct et ils vont tout
fait la faute puisqu'il fait tout
reprend ses sept qui se dit ben tant pis
il trouve pas de défense alors qu'en
fait ils auraient pu tenter le coup ici
sans doute tour g3 quand même en
laissant prendre un f5
mais en créant royal et un petit réseau
delà puisque le roi va essayer de créer
une contrebasse sas auront été tout à
fait tout à fait jouable parce que sur
ici une prise en effet cinq si on on
serait obligé les changes et les dames
parce qu'en cas de prise échec
et là on a un problème on peut pas
bouger faudrait ramener la tour ici mais
ayant un match de l'autre côté c'est des
accidents 30 mois là il y aurait dans
prend pour prendre et c'est matt donc
c'est une défense en contre attaque et
voit tout n'a pas vu cette possibilité
il est sous pression le pion aux cinq
risquent de tomber et il fait la faute
il fait tout procès cet effet tout
simplement il perd le fou il peut même
pas prendre le cavalier avec un tour
parce que ça les lie pour deschamps et
la menace a hissé de venir
donc ça c'est la faute final du ventoux
mais on voit bien que la leur sort de
l'estonienne noir a fait son effet et
que finalement une attaque blanche a
bien été contrôlé sur les dames et que
l'ouverture du centre a bien profité à
la masse man 2 pièces noires les angles
engoncé salle estonienne ce qui il ya
évidemment c'est très calculatoire haut
niveau au niveau je dirai au plus haut
niveau il faut calculer toutes les
variantes mais dans la réalité ce qui se
passe c'est que les simples coups de
libération aux bons moments permettent
de libérer une force telle que en
général on arrive à équilibrer les
menaces de la part des vraies menaces de
maths et souvent fait mal d'ailleurs ce
qui nous montre aussi que les idées en
philosophie en histoire aux échecs ont
une vie il ya des idées qui sont à la
mode et des idées qui disparaît si des
idées qui reviennent exactement mais on
voit ici que l'idée de cette estaing
diène revient entre garer mais
suffisamment efficace pour remporter une
belle victoire dans un tournoi aussi
prestigieux relevé que le chorus
peut-être que j'ai à nouveau une mode de
l'escalier à vis assez radjabov depuis
quelques années déjà examiné deux ans je
crois qu'il a remis ça au jour et ça
fait ça fait vraiment plaisir cette
partie est significative et elle est
allée symptomatique de l'estonienne
elle est très belle et tous les thèmes
qu'on a vu là sont symptomatiques sont
sont classiques sont classiques sont de
cette ouverture puis on prend 1,6 des
ventes ou alors qui sans nous tromper
dans les calculs parce que la suite est
facile pour un des boss 3f 4 et après
tout prime quatre échecs
il n'y a pas de solution il faut jouer
3g un classique
la dame g5 échec par la tour et la
partie s'arrête là parce que la suite et
est très facile à taux et le pion ne
suffisent pas évidemment à jouer en plus
on va le roi c'est pas évident de
trouver un chat alors si si le roi va un
chien c'est c'est pareil d'emprunt f4
les blancs ne peuvent même pas prendre
le set à cause de maths et si le roi va
ici sur la case est viable par exemple
il ya prise avec échec et on défende
cavalli donc il n'y a aucun problème
pour les noirs pour finir cette partie
ivantchouk abandonne sur saône mg5 puis
abandonnée avant dans son erreur ça
aurait été comme une sphère tous
pensaient qu'il pouvait encore tenir la
position mais le ressort des noirs
étaient déjà très fort et je pense qu'il
a attendu le 40e concours abandonné sans
doute va y avoir un petit problème de
temps peut-être un petit problème de
temps 2 et note évidemment pour pour
radjabov où ils vont tous les deux très
belles parties classiques qui aurait pu
terminer par la nuls sur 9 ans un peu
plus précise des blancs
on a vu les grands thèmes de cette
énième stratégie la tape à l'oeil dames
le centre et la façon dont les noirs ont
forcé cette prise de prison et 5
d'autres d'autres types de solutions
sont envisageables pour les blancs mais
qui n'ont pas n'ont pas été prises en
opérant dans cette partie et une belle
partie avec ce resort un bon moment ou
jamais se laisser enfermer le fou g7
jamais permettre aux blancs de tenir la
case ou 4
donc il gardait toujours ce contrôle
soit qu'asuka ou carrément dans ce cas
là s'il ya des chaînes de pions ce
conseil assume parti suisse et
manoeuvres de cavaliers toujours qu'il
faut pas jouer plusieurs fois la mairie
mais l'arrêt en l'occurrence voilà
exception c'est une position ferme et
c'est une position ferme et donc faut
pas hésiter dans une position ferme et à
chercher la meilleure case pour les
pièces dans là on a quelquefois le temps
notamment des cavaliers de se lancer
dans une longue manoeuvre tout à fait
qui permet de trouver la meilleure case
tout à fait là on va rappeler pour nos
spectateurs jérôme tapiès donc jusqu'au
2 mai période des transferts à la
comédie saint-michel vous pouvez
réserver vos places réellement facile
d'y aller parce que c'est à dix mètres
de la sortie du rer b luxembourg
airware luxembourg au commissaire michel
comme le prêt on serait optionnelle du
héros voilà exactement et on doit te
retrouver très bientôt sur le hero
céline et puis on va évidemment aller
voir cette magnifique pièce si on suivra
7,7 ce déploiement pédagogie du jeu
d'échecs dans l'académie de créteil
tu me tiendrai au courant évidemment
bien sûr y compris de cette étude
complémentaire à celle de michel noir on
finira par accumulés sans doute des
informations oui un corpus théorique
suffisante pour toujours dans le même
but développer notre passion montrer aux
institutions et aux langues de nerfs
qu'il y a un potentiel très fort de
développement que c'est un jeu qui a une
telle virtuosité crois qu'il faut pas
hésiter à le rappeler elle répétait nous
on sait entre nous on en a la conviction
il faut aussi savoir en convaincre les
autres mais trop c'est aussi c'est qu'il
existe depuis 1500 ans et que un jeu qui
dure aussi autant de temps sur monde est
sûrement quelque chose de particulier
dans ses quelque chose de particulier
merci de nous avoir suivis pour ce
diagonale tv spéciale chorus 2009
religion mon frein et
sa pièce de théâtre période de transfert
à aller voir d'urgence
merci de nous suivre pour des deux sur
des monotypes je rappelais diabolo tv
disponible sur internet
www.diagnocure.com vous accès à toutes
les archives de l'émission
merci de nous suivre de nous est fidèle
et puis je vous dis à une prochaine fois
sur diagonale tv merci du rhône merci
beaucoup
à bientôt au revoir